welcome to this video playing soco Zuko
from from the UK let's see what we get
here like Madame a gambit or the result
for ya this is a what is this type of
trying for the black madam oh but
prepare it that looks really strange wow
if i take here you take with the Queen
remarkable now it's at some red still
quite quite quick development but still
hard to believe if i go bishop may be
here or e6 yeah e 6 is probably not bad
as well yeah but ok this should be
simple and good if you take that you
take with the bishop p 597 esox I cannot
believe in the pond second I should have
a pretty good pretty good type of French
depends with the light squared Bishop
being gone already
I don't really believe that this is any
good de-spawn sec with the light squared
bishops being off the board I mean his
light squared Bishop I know he just
traits it why Wow okay i will i will
even get an e5 here g6 Bishop g7 85
okay just five young and now should i do
ii six even though maybeee 695 so h6
first age six then e six and Bishop d6
keeping the the center Bishop pio 94 I
can just retreat yeah and let's prevent
f4 all together okay so he's trying to
to take it with 93 that actually a good
idea so what should I just cover it
castles will get five I guess so
quite quite amazed that this is intact
playable for white
hmm
don't really see how I keep this I mean
I can't checking can bring the King to
f6 maybe I mean if you move the bishop
and the g4 I mean f3 is hanging so
that's not not a big problem
yeah b4 b5 check was quite a threat k 33
but now d 4 gets more attractive ok yes
night f-22 if form i also have edgy for
him ok check
93 i also have Luke age five okay so he
wants to play after the capture wants to
know where you cannot do that division
saying first 93 I take and i take the
bishop yeah this is very nice no
this was amazingly unclear after this
very weird opening
yeah I've got two bishops against them
against the rook check the don't mind
trades makes it easy em technically the
F bond is probably going to win or some
of the other pawns quite quite a nice
bow information here in the center 95
cos also very nice check
ok I'll keep it simple now the upon
white resign yeah that was mentioned
amazingly amazingly unclear maybe I
played it the Batu to relax TM I mean I
really can't believe this is any good e
six maybe p.m. I don't know maybe here
as I can do something better the sun
night f-22 a 2d three years some quite
um quite interesting a computer has a
very hard were here to combat that wants
to play h5 so that this is prevented
interesting and this is a clear edge for
black yeah I didn't this is didn't cross
my mind and now I recognize that it
isn't so clear really
yeah maybe maybe why this okay it's hard
to get any any headway and oh here I
could have played g4 yeah I was sort of
immediately reacting to the be five mins
b5 takes however as total win now okay
so check and here you should have done
something else the computer wants to
play a 4 here mmm they form a tail a
form i probably have to play b6 and to
give away the spawn and still I have g4
yeah this is how I was very good again
here blackity black is in fact winning
yeah it was amazingly complicated after
this weird opening line okay thanks for
watching